how's it going man i'm carlos
what's up man nice fit hey you too
everyone this is the this is the
drippiest cast i've seen at comic con
very drippy we kind of we kind of um
compete you know
everybody's like what are you wearing
what are you wearing but we actually um
we have like nice conversations giving
each other our input on our fashions
nice was there any uh any costume that
you wore that you thought i could make
this work on a day-to-day basis this is
why no absolutely no
there's nothing in my costumes that i
could wear on a day-to-day basis
everything is very much middle-earth
everything is very much
of that and
impractical in our human world yeah can
you tell me about the feeling that you
had today being out there in front of
this crowd that's so ready for this show
and like premiering that footage for the
first time
i mean i
we've been we've been talking about this
for a long time you know um
i i heard that we were gonna feel like
rock stars
and i think that was confirmed you know
we felt i think we all felt like rock
stars but it was more
it's from the love that was like there's
a wave of love that was coming towards
us um people
i know that this is so beloved for a lot
of people and people are wanting us to
to thrive and to succeed so
i don't know i was i just i was just
present taking it in and just like
everything i'm i'm extremely happy to be
here so we know this show takes place in
ages like thousands of years before the
trilogy that people have seen
is your character relate in any way to
any of the characters that people know
from those movies my character is
originally written for the show so it's
not a canonical character
but it is as the show runners have said
you know there's many gaps in uh or many
different characters that come through
in uh the legendarium and the other
works and um you know they built some of
our characters from all those references
so they're definitely uh part of
tolkien's world yeah what's it like
being able to be here like you guys went
away to new zealand to work on this for
almost two years and it's like nobody
gets to know about what's going on right
no one from the outside world
to be here and share this experience
with your cast what's it like
it
it makes it real
you know because we work together for so
long and and but in our own bubble we're
creating during the pandemic we're
locked in
new zealand which gave us an incredible
safe home to make this work but we were
all
we were all part of the sauce you know
we're like kind of reading the newspaper
like this you know now we're getting to
have a little bit of a distance but also
the missing piece is everyone else the
missing piece is the audience so it's
it's making it's completing a cycle
kind of because
really the completion is going to be
when those episodes are out and you can
see them you can sit down and
talk about them share and all that good
stuff
what member of the original trilogy cast
would you like kind of lose it to find
out became a fan of this show and your
character i mean from the original
trilogy
undoubtedly ian mckellen
you know i mean sir ian mckellen it's uh
i've loved him through everything that
he's done i mean magneto for example
gandalf you know so i would i would
officially lose it that's awesome dude
congratulations thanks for your time
you